as a football fan fascinating to see
what happens when kyler murray and
tuatanga viloa
cross paths for the first time at the
nfl level unfortunately we only see it
once every four years they're in
different conferences
but we're going to see it peter tua and
the dolphins
going to arizona to take on kyler murray
here is
a little tua talking about kyler and a
little kyler talking about tua listen up
i'm very excited to go up against him i
would say
first impressions when i when i met him
he's
you know he's pretty jacked up you know
for for as
you know short as he is he's he's i mean
this guy's rocked up
but he's very competitive um
you know he's very personable too i got
to meet his parents as well at the
heisman ceremony
very good family um you know but against
going against guys like that who are
very competitive and you know you're
going to get their best
i think that's going to be a fun one
doing the whole
heisman you know the college football
awards um
he was hurt at the time but you know his
family and they're
one of a kind you know really really
nice people great people
showed nothing but love throughout that
whole day you know the whole week
nice to me nice to my family you know
obviously the love was
reciprocated but not two was uh you know
the times that i've been around him
nothing you know i can't say anything
bad about you a
great dude down to earth great players
you know i love both of those guys as
human beings and i really love kylie
murray as a quarterback with two at the
nfl level we just don't know yet
what was your impression based upon the
limited
slice that we got of tuatanga vailoa
last week against the rams
you know it's almost like chan galey
threw a protective cloak over him
really the offensive coordinator the
dolphins
you know he didn't have a chance to do a
whole lot um
i think you know if on your report card
after a game like that you get an eye
for incomplete
exactly i don't exactly know what to i
don't have i said
the same thing what to think of tua yeah
i mean yeah just
i don't have any idea but but i will i
will just say this
mike and i don't mean to go too far
afield okay
i have been saying that i really wish
that the nfl would change the way they
schedule
uh non-division games okay so you have
obviously
and i i know this is a distraction but i
just i've got to say it
so you've got your six division games
every year that leaves 10 other games
i believe that two of those games every
year should be kept
as what i would call wild card games and
what i mean is that every year in the
off season
i think that howard katz and his
scheduling team the nfl football
operations team should get together and
should say you know what
we want a tua versus
uh uh kyler game this year
i would almost want to see that game
almost every year
but and and like you know if if tom
brady and drew brees were in opposite
conferences this year i would have said
this could be the last year for brees
and for brady who knows
i want to see them play against each
other one more time
because it's almost it's almost unfair
that these guys never play against each
other
uh it just it's unfair for the football
fan
and i know that people are going to be
crying about uh well then
you're gonna have a bunch of detroit
cleveland games well
you know okay some way you're gonna have
to pay the price
to get great games every week
in cross-conference scheduling
but that's just one thing i wanted to
say i'm curious what do you think of
that
well look the and and this is one fact
about the nfl that has been ignored
because the pandemic arrived and turned
everyone's life upside down
next year there's 17 games so
they got to figure out where they're
going to get that 17th game they've got
a perfect formula now
it's a little complicated but it's not
not all that complicated once you figure
it out and it's the same every year
and it gets every team
playing in theory in every stadium over
an eight year period it gets every fan
that's got season tickets in a position
to see
every team on an eight year cycle but
you've got that extra game now what are
you going to do with it and and i have
an idea for it that i forget what it is
i'd have to look it up but one thing you
could do is just make it a year by year
we're going to be mad scientists here
and we're going to create these
match-ups
that we think are going to be compelling
for football fans and let's put
let's put tua and kyler together this
year with this extra game
have them play have them play each other
next year if
if it's only one game i would take it
i'd rather have it be two
but if it's only one game i will take it
my only point is mike
it is unfair in my opinion in the grand
scheme of things honestly uh
to have uh you know basically to have
russell wilson
playing patrick mahomes once every four
years
it's just it's ridiculous quite honestly
you know
they might play each other only two or
three times
ever it's just it's it it's really it
just
i don't want to say it's heartbreaking
but i just think it's i think it's awful
that you don't take advantage of your
mega stars
i mean what would the rating be this
year
on a sunday night game with uh patrick
mahomes and russell wilson
with their two teams playing well with i
mean it'd be
utterly fantastic those guys should play
if not every year every other year
well and peter you know to to take your
point one step farther before we get
back to the game
the fact that the nfl currently is
negotiating with all the networks on the
next round of multi-billion dollar
annual contracts
that's something the nfl could bring to
the table to sweeten the pot we're not
just gonna have a formula
that determines this 17th game every
year
we are going to come up with that slate
of
extra games that otherwise would not be
spat out by our
annual this is how it is this is how it
is this is how it is
we're going to find those extra games
they're going to be inner conference
games and we're going to give you
match-ups
16 match-ups that yeah you know a few of
them are going to be
but but there's going to be 17 17
matchups
well one extra week of games 16 extra
games so
one extra yeah one extra week of games
is 16 extra games so we're going to give
you those match ups
cross conference and you're going to be
thrilled
with half of them maybe maybe with 10 or
12 of them there's going to be some
clunkers
that's fine but there's going to be some
great games that are over and above what
you otherwise would get on the schedule
all right so we do get tua and kyler
this week and if i'm a dolphins fan
i'm just a little nervous i'm a little
uneasy because we saw joe burrow
instantly he was clearly good enough
instantly justin herbert with literally
one minute advance notice because tyrod
taylor got the needle in the lung
clearly he's got it with tua i'm on the
edge of my seat every possession against
the cardinals
i want to see that spark peter i want to
see that flash i want to see that thing
that tells me
he's good enough last week mike i
watched a lot of that to a game
and i i mean if if i'm just watching
that game that's about the fourth thing
fourth piece of conversation out of that
game you know what the number one
uh absolute headline in that game
miami's defense is damn good
okay they're playing a team with a good
offensive line not the best offensive
line in football
they swarmed jared goff the entire day
they really got after him they were
tough they were physical and i look at
that game mike
and i just say okay now kyler murray is
a
different challenge than jared goff he's
a different challenge from almost every
other quarterback
but in my opinion you are going to see
a swarming defense and kyler murray is
going to have to be
very elusive in this game or else he's
going to get the crap beat out of him
in my opinion after watching that game
last weekend
yeah i i agree with you and uh the
dolphins
are doing well right now the cardinals
are doing well both teams in position to
make a run at the post
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports